natürlich freue ich mich für dich nur
die umstände wir sind denkbar ungünstig
bitte welche umstände
es gibt schon genügend enge oder private
bindung zwischen menschen die an diesem
projekt arbeiten
was redest du da solche raus mit der
sprache
alex und lukas zum beispiel alex ist in
lukas verknallt und mag also franziska
deponie dich mal für dieses musik
magazin fotografiert hat sie ist marx
verlobte was aber keiner wissen soll
mark und ich haben auch eine
vergangenheit wie du weißt kölscher
klüngel ist ein witz dagegen aber laut
diesem lukas haben die porträts den
ausschlag gegeben
ja es stimmt dass ich dein gesicht auf
der vernissage abhängig sehen was für
eine vernissage
ich habe das gefühl wir leben völlig
aneinander vorbei haka tanz dazu
einladen also alex und mich mag der ist
mir ganz wichtig natürlich ist unser
projektleiter ich meine nicht beruflich
sondern privat für dich
wie kommst du darauf vom taxifahrer zum
kreativen projekt lange zeit nicht das
natürlich bereit
ich gehe noch was trinken und das ist
der olymp es hat sich so einiges
verändert aber der schaden liegt siehst
du keine sein dorf ach komm schon
irgendwann werden sie erfahre ich aber
doch nicht jetzt
hallo ach so spät noch bei der arbeit
und selbst brainstorming unter kollegen
mark hatte vorgeschlagen mir ein paar
kneipen zu zeigen obwohl ich befürchte
dass mich das nicht ins bewegt als
ehemaliger taxifahrer kennst du dich so
aus oder ja klar so schnell verliert man
das nicht
dann könntest du den beiden einen
ehemaligen kollegen
ich gehe lieber zu fuß ich habe schon
nicht so weit
du wirst sicher noch bleiben ist nichts
sag ich bring dich mach tun
habt ihr zwei beinen für die damen und
in köln gerne du bist georgiers
ex-freund richtig kaum wiederzuerkennen
herisau ist nora ist was von lotta
gehört ich komme gerade zur tür rein
dort bist du zu hause hier bin ich ja da
war es mal kurz was ist passiert geht
sehr gut von dem kind sagt er dass alles
in ordnung ist
ich ruhe mich kurz aus und was sie
gleich zurück
nur hier geht's gut sie wehrte sich
gleich mit dem ok jetzt schon
sie hatten
das ist völlig normale manchmal heißt
mein körper stellt sich nur die frage
wie konnte ich nicht anrufen weil mein
handy kaputt gegangen ist
obwohl den abend arbeit verbunden hast
von des total sicher
die sind sehr schön mit dir du kannst
hey islamische